welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and star wars celebration gave us
lucky attendees exclusive trailer
footage of the mandalorian season 3 and
ahsoka while the weekend gave everybody
in the world updates about obi-wan
kenobi and or bad batch skeleton crew
and the jedi survivor game also willow
cool i was super lucky to be there in
person for all of it i forgot to wear
some sunscreen when i was outside for a
lot of it but i had a blast meeting so
many awesome star wars fans and because
i love you all so much including those
of you who couldn't go i wanted to break
down all the news and footage that i was
able to see so that everyone knows what
you need to know and let's start with
the mandalorian season 3 coming february
2023 i attended the thursday lucasfilm
studio showcase and broke down the
footage that i saw there but the
saturday mando plus panel showed an
expanded version of the trailer which is
still not online so let's break down
what's in it a reminder that the first
step of this trailer focuses mostly on
mando and grogu with boca ton crees who
is still bitter that mando currently
wields a darksaber complicating her
claim to the throne of mandalore but
what throne really is it because we do
see her sitting on a throne but it looks
like [ __ ] and she snares your cult gave
up on mandalore long before the purge
where were you then so shots fired for
bogatan to call the watch a cult because
really from the point of view of every
other mandalorian who's okay with
showing their face the watch are totally
a group of culti zealots now the last
scene with pokaton and rebels showed
clan beasley swear loyalty to her so
something went down during the galactic
civil war with the remnants of the death
watch but before the purge bombing of
sundari that we saw in the book of boba
fett flashback also in this section
mando declares i'm going to mandalore so
that i may be forgiven for my
transgressions and then we see him
spelunking in the minds of mandalore to
the living waters of mandalore
presumably for some kind of baptismal
blessing akin to the gaffey tree ritual
that boba fett had with the tuscans
we're gonna be learning a lot about the
spirituality of the mandalorian culture
and how back to the days of tarvisla
some of their mythology and their
spiritual beliefs may be even
intertwined with the jedi order a
mandalorian season three will revisit
navarro with grief karga coming back and
captain carson teva also with a tree
full of kawakian monkey lizards and it
will revisit tatooine with pelimoto's
repair shop we also see the return of
the mysterious imperial geneticist dr
pershing and we might learn what his
connections might have been with the
kaminoans like nala say but the second
half of this trailer that we annoyed it
was coming was revealed at the mando
plus panel on saturday and it is even
crazier this footage shows way more
action including a battle that includes
the mandalorian warriors including paz
wiesla with this heavy repeating blaster
and bo katan and other mandalorians in
night owl looking armor plunging from a
dropship the armorer clubs a quarren
with her best car hammer and then babu
frick appears our beloved droid
repairman from the rise of skywalker
alongside two others of his race the
anzellons but then the true glory shot
of all this mando and grogu in the
modded n1 naboo starfighter over the
smoky ruins of the bombed mandalorian
city of sundari underneath which
presumably are those mines of mandalore
in the living waters so it looks like
season three is going to be focused very
much on bogitan the history of the
mandalorian people and their cultural
differences but a fourth season is in
the works currently being written by
john favreau but let's move on to ahsoka
so the mano plus panel confirmed the
early rumors that sabine ran will be
played by natasha leo bordizzo sabine
was a major character in rebels season 3
and 4 an imperial defector coming from
the mandalorian house of ren she takes
on the darksaber after rescuing ezra
bridger from maul she trains with it she
defeats gar saxon with it on cronus and
later hands it off to bogatan and many
of us believe that in all those handoffs
no one actually dueled to properly claim
the blade that could have been the curse
that bo katan inherited and why she
struggled to rule mandalore the panel
also unveiled the astromech droid from
rebels chopper the little [ __ ] whom
some consider a war criminal considering
in season 2 he sabotaged a star
destroyer and also took out two imperial
cruisers and estimated 50 000 kills but
really if we're gonna use that logic
many of the heroes in clone wars and
rebels were war criminals ahsoka is
really looking like a live-action
version of rebels gonna give you a brief
description of the trailer footage that
i saw it opens actually with ahsoka in a
cockpit this is the cockpit of the ghost
the vcx 100 light freighter really the
home base of the rebels series another
shot shows us the bridge of the ghost
with its captain the twilight hera
syndulla seeing them from behind no
update on the actor yet we saw the ghost
in live action in rogue one
participating in the battle of scarif
and harrison dilla was name dropped back
at the yavin iv base having risen to the
rank of general general
there's also a live-action version of
zeb also appears here as well as the
droid huyang from clone wars that was
the mark iv architect droid who taught
young jedi on the crucible there's also
a shot of a hand using the force to try
to summon a cup i was thinking maybe
ezra but i don't think ezra would really
struggle with forced pulse at this point
so maybe we're looking at a new force
sensitive recruit or we could be seeing
a group of young jedi survivors who were
alive on the crucible at the time of
order 66. the final shot of this ahsoka
trailer is a live-action recreation of
the final scene of rebels with sabine
stepping up to the mural of ezra bridger
and the whole ghost crew before turning
around to join ahsoka in a search for
ezra this shot is bordeza with purple
hair the shot is live action but the
mural is the same 2d art rendition from
that animated scene looks like they're
re-staging it shot for shot here now a
reminder that ezra disappeared along
with the villain thrawn due to the
pergold the hyperspace whales who
actually in obi-wan kenobi episode 1
bail organa told leia that he used to
want to hunt now when we saw live-action
ahsoka in mandalorian season two she
fought morgan ellsbeth demanding where
is your master
where is grand admiral thrawn and i
assume this season of ahsoka will be
during the post-return of the jedi
mandalorian boba fett era with the
ahsoka still looking for thrawn but it
looks like we'll also be seeing a bit of
a split timeline or maybe flashbacks to
the rebels era which is right before the
events of a new hope so we've maybe seen
another timeline that is concurrent with
the original trilogy i understand that
sometimes you feel like you have to have
a galaxy brain to understand some of
these theories but you know you don't
have to be a galaxy brain to invest in
cryptocurrency public.com is here to
help public.com is an investing platform
that helps people be better investors
soon on public members will be able to
build a portfolio with any fractional
asset stocks etfs crypto art and
collectibles what makes public so
special is the platform combines the
ease of fractional investing with an
educational community filled with
like-minded investors you can learn and
share ideas directly in the social feed
they also have notable business leaders
in there you can ask them questions and
see them respond directly in the app
public now offers 30 different cryptos
for you to trade including bitcoin ether
dogecoin and more there are a ton of
educational resources in the app to help
you make an informed decision there are
zero commission fees on standard trades
and no account minimums to get started
new rockstars is on public and you can
see what trends we're following if you
search for at new rockstars in the app
so go to public.com new rockstars and
receive a free stock between three
dollars and three hundred dollars when
you open an account with public and
deposit now the thursday panel announced
skeleton crew that's john watts series
set during the mandalorian era a working
title being grammar rodeo this is gonna
be following a group of kids who get
lost in the galaxy previously described
as an amblin-esque coming-of-age story
favre and polonie were saying that this
is a story about kids but not
necessarily for kids alone jude law has
been announced to star and i speculated
that it could be the actor who this
series is really positioning to be
thrawn with thrawn showing up in several
titles both this one and ahsoka but
that's just my theory nothing's been
confirmed yet but of course the next
star wars title coming out after obi-wan
later this summer is andorr first two
episodes coming august 31st this is
going to be a 12 episode season with a
second season confirmed with another 12
episodes so we're getting a lot of andor
showing how this rebel spy spent all of
his time leading up to rogue one the
trailer shows the two eras of cassian
andor his home planet before it's
destroyed in a clone wars era conflict
and then a new planet that he resettles
on as an adult as it gets radicalized
under imperial rule looks like the local
authorities are going to be a puppet
government with a kind of curfew
announced every night with this
colonized baskar bell mon mothma plays a
part in an empty coruscant senate
stellan skarsgard and fiona shaw are
rebel leaders plotting attacks on an
imperial labor camp that builds star
destroyers bad batch season 2 released a
new trailer it's coming fall 2020 the
trailer shows the return of commander
cody remember him he was obi-wan's clone
commander who shot at him on udap we
also see this wookie jedi padawan ganji
he survived and then we see emperor
palpatine in that senate chamber
chronologically just a few years before
we see mon mothma in the andor trailer
here you can see it's still being
repaired refused together after
palpatine's duel with yoda in revenge of
the sith tells of the jedi is an
animated series coming spring 2023 the
footage shown exclusively at celebration
shows two story lines across six
episodes one storyline following young
dooku and featuring cameos by qui-gon
jinn liam neeson's returning to voice
cameos also including mace windu and
yaddle the other storyline's gonna
follow ahsoka that flashes back to her
past including her mother pobty and a
run-in with the inquisitor the sixth
brother showing us a visual version of
what you might have read in ek
johnston's 2016 novel also in 2023 will
be a second volume of star wars visions
throughout the weekend we got no updates
on the acolyte and then when it comes to
star wars movies remember they used to
make movies at the studio kathleen
kennedy indicated that the tiger wood tt
movie is in early development and could
come late 2023 but nothing has been
locked in yet but also coming to 123
will be the jedi fallen order sequel
jedi survivor with a teaser showing the
mantis ship wrecked a glimpse of a powen
imperial official but i don't think it's
a grand inquisitor and then cal and bd1
finding a mysterious jedi survivor in a
bacta tank with one arm so it might be
that same one-armed red lightsaber
wielder that he fights in other shots
but this back to tank looks abandoned
some are speculating it could be rom
coda from force unleashed or a character
from legends we've talked about on the
tournament before jorus sebaoth a young
version of him but i think it's a new
character like some jedi that was just
left healing in a back to tank forgotten
after order 66 and rediscovered by cow
jedi survivor is confirmed to be set
five years after falling order meaning
it's gonna be set around the same time
as the current obi-wan kobe series
making a live-action calcus slightly
more likely to show up in the series now
our breakdowns for kenobi episodes one
and two are live on the channel episode
three is coming out tomorrow with
episodes four five and six coming
wednesdays in june although you and
mcgregor teased additional episodes
seven eight nine and ten really was just
joking around echoing what someone in
the crowd said i'm very much enjoying
this obi-wan kenobi series and i love
that it's really secretly an obi-wan in
leia series so i can't wait to break
down the rest of it with you the best
way to support any rockstars is checking
out our merch options over at new
rockstarsmerch.com we have a new obi-wan
kenobi inspired latest obsession shirt
getting one of these we'll give you the
added option to write in a custom shout
out that will appear at the bottom of
our wikileaks after shows you can follow
me on instagram twitter at eavos follow
the new rockstar subscribe to new york
stars for more analysis of everything
you love thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you